[music]
[music
] Dear President,
first of all, thank you very much for
your sympathy for the flood victims and those
affected in Germany.
We appreciate that very much.
Stress and I ask you  also for understanding
that i would like to say a few words about this
because in the flooded places
in north rhine-westphalia and
rhineland-palatinate the day is
almost over
a day of fear for life and possession
of worry and despair
hundreds of thousands had to experience that
their everyday  Surroundings where suddenly
became a disaster area, residential houses
, death traps, rivers, torrential
waters and I fear
you will only see the full extent of the tragedy in
the next few days and my
heartfelt condolences go to all those
who
have lost relatives and friends to this catastrophe or who are
still missing  I am also concerned about
the people in the
flooded areas of
Belgium  rescue workers do enormous things and
the most difficult and dangerous
conditions i thank you for what
can i say that the suffering of those
affected affects me very much
i know that millions of people in
germany feel the same way i let myself be
kept up to date with the situation all day long with  dear
president dear joe biden thank you very much
for the invitation to washington  for
the intensive discussions
it's my first visit here
since 2009 10 i'm very happy about
the personal exchange we
and we realized that today we are
not only allies and partners but also
closely friendly nations and i would also like to
thank you for suggesting our from
us a common  values and the will to meet the c
allenges of our time and i
am deeply convinced that simpl
committing to the values is of course enou
h, but that we live in a very cruc
al time in which, as a
example, new challenges
re of course implemented in practical p
litics  that's why i'm very grateful that we have based
our common foundations but also
future projects in the
washington declaration and i
'm pleased that we will have a
german-american
future forum that will deal with exactly these
questions
our
societies will discuss and find solutions together  i think
such structures are very important the
great degree of commonality was also shown
in our conversation we
talked about overcoming the
pandemic we are convinced that
this can only succeed if not only
our countries are the people there for a long time
t and we also want
as many as possible to be vaccinated
but that we should support all countries in the
world with
vaccines
the work is bubacks together and
i would like to thank you for a
bright from america under your
leadership but also a clear
commitment to multilateralism  always
but also in the world
sphere
, the world health organization but also the world
germany and the usa have therefore
agreed to send vaccine doses to developing countries
as donations that we also work
to a large extent with the growing
topicality
we have talked about the challenge of
climate change and i am  very
very happy that the united states have returned
to the paris court
and that we have a completely
different basis in glasgow to also fight together at
the conference of the parties for more
climate protection i think the
meteorological events whether they are fires
the united s  States are being hit by
dramatically high temperatures or
completely and regulated rainfall All of
this indicates that the number of
extraordinary weather events
has increased dramatically in recent
years and we have to react to that
and Germany and the USA have now entered into an
energy and climate
partnership that we can  he
decided is an important
sign
it is about the expansion of sustainable
technologies such as hydrogen green
hydrogen such as renewable energies
such as e-mobility and much
more and we are in competition
with others around the world and
germany is looking forward to
working together just as much  i support
the infrastructure project proposed by the president for
a worldwide
expansion of infrastructures as a result of
which we decided at the b7 conference that
germany will have the presidency next year
and they
will go into the project
with the addition - further ahead  attach we
talked about russia and ukraine in this context
was needed 10 2 we have
different assessments of what
this project will entail but we
say very clearly our understanding
was and is and will remain the sovereign
transit country your
natural gas remains that ukraine  every country is also entitled
to territorial sovereignty,
so we are also committed to the
process and that we will also act actively
if russia does not redeem this right
essener hoff tranches country
that means for me two is still an
additional project and no project
instead  transit of gas through
ukraine and everything else would
cause a lot of tension and we
are also talking about how we
could make that clear together
we have talked about other
foreign policy we are talking about here
especially the relationship with china
we are countries  the democratic
free sat  enter into communities that live in such societies, of
course, this also makes allowance for the fact that
we make our disagreement clear where human rights are not
guaranteed,
we also
stand by the territorial
integrity of all countries and we
also have the many facets of
cooperation or even
china in terms of competition law  spoken in the
economic area,
climate protection, the military area,
questions of security and here, of
course, there are many challenges
with the nokia agreement with iran,
we are of the opinion that everything should be
done and that a good conclusion can now
be reached, but i think you
can say that it has  but iran
we were
happy to talk about afghanistan there soldiers served together there for
many years they averted
terrorist threats but of course
we didn't succeed sufficiently in building
a nation,
nor did viruses lead us to a nation  tell
and still i say it was a good
partnership with a
united states of america in
between our soldiers and the
german soldiers especially
appreciate this
region where terrorism is
rampant and from the european
perspective it is of course a big
challenge  and we would like to thank the
states of america for their
use in the anti-terrorist mission
. finally, we may have
agreed on a german-american
economic german-american
economic dialogue in
which our business people can also
exchange ideas because we have
considerable trade with each other
should be expanded the
economic
relations are of course of the utmost importance to us
it was a friendly exchange
i would like that to remain after my
time as federal chancellor
we have created a few conditions
so that you can continue to omit safe  really be
a challenge
[music]
63 points
for every german chancellor every
german chancellor in the very best
interests of germany to work with every
american president
we always had press conferences and
you can  everyone is always convinced
[music]
thank you very much madam chancellor mr
president i have a question about the
nord stream 2 madam chancellor
you just said you would
act actively if russia fulfills its commitments
, for example interrupting gas transit
through ukraine, what do you mean by that?
specifically,
germany is then meant to say that the
german side
is shutting down nord stream and how should that be legally
justified under the president of the united
states have now fought for so many years against
nord stream 2 now from the
operating company maybe even
only a few days are left the united will be finished
St  aaten let this pipeline
go into operation
or does the operating company
perhaps also
have to adjust to the fact that it
will be dealt with by the German
management?
don't speculate about instruments i just
want to say
[music]
now, of course, chancellor
china was also on the agenda.
i wanted to ask you if you have the
feeling that after your conversation, president
biden understands yours better
viewpoints better understand that
china or if the situation is still
tense regarding so-called decoupling 2
if you think the usa has done enough to
make the world similar
or if you think it is
appropriate that here the usa never be vaccinated around children under the
age of twelve  will
adult other countries
[music]
we talked about china and there
is a common understanding
of how to act what we live in a time
of digitization and of course
[music]
sometimes there are of course also have to
meet with china on the
common values
we are actually that the pan
minho can be fought if this person
we have also happened in europe
the european production but and of
course also used
that leads to critical discussions with
countries today we do
everything equal to overcoming
merkel
you have  spoken
to the companies have you heard the complaints the
concerns
some have threatened to move the business away
from the us what was your
main argument today for promoting a
performance of the trend and
do you feel you got away with it
[music]
[  music]
answer get the president given him now
[music]